at school if you're not super smart okay
if you're not really academic and you're
going to struggle to get into University
and you're going to struggle to get a
job maybe it's easy to think oh well I'm
not going to be able to be successful
I'm not going to be able to make much
money I'm not going to be able to amount
to anything but actually I didn't do
super well in school I tried really hard
in school I put my all into it but
naturally I wasn't as smart as many as
the other kids but even though I was at
school I wasn't that smart I was
constantly thinking well what am I good
at you know maybe I'm not good at doing
English exams maybe I'm not good at
maths but what am I good at and I
realized I was quite good at making
money so I got some paper rounds and I
started working you know while I was at
school and
again if you're not super smart
academically let's say let's say right
now you're thinking man I'm not as smart
as Sally I'm not as smart as Ben they're
going to be so much more successful than
me okay
maybe you might think I have to go on to
do something like be a builder or be a
mechanic I need to if I can't use my
brain at going to University maybe I
have to use my hands become a masseuse
or something and that's what I thought
so in the six week School summer holiday
what everyone else was playing and go
and and just going out in the sunshine
and stuff I signed up for a course it
was a seven day course
and it taught me how to be a plasterer
now plasterer is when you make you
plaster the wall so if there's like
brick walls and you want to make them
nice and shine you're ready to paint you
have to learn how to plaster the walls
so I learned to plaster and I thought I
was really good at Plastering after
seven days I was like I'm so good at
plastering I'm gonna start making money
as a plasterer so I'll put a little
advert in the newspaper cost me 15
pounds put a little Advent in the
newspaper and I said if anybody wants a
plasterer book me evenings and weekends
however I thought I was really good
Plastering but I wasn't actually that
good
because I took on this job to plaster a
whole room
and I started Plastering the room but
what what I forgot is they didn't teach
me on the course how to plaster ceilings
so I'm trying to I'm trying to plaster
this ceiling
but it's not really working and all the
plaster's falling down on me and I
remember the client the person that was
paying me she's there watching me
plaster and I'm there and I'm like
really embarrassed thinking this is
terrible the plaster's falling down on
me and she's standing there she's this
Big Rich you know lady that's paying me
to plaster she's standing there watching
she's asking me she said Samuel
she says you're not really a plasterer a
tall liar and I was like oh my gosh this
is so embarrassing so I was like no well
the thing is I'm kind of still learning
but I said I will get this job finished
I will give me a couple days and I'll
get this job finished and she's okay so
she leaves so I'm there trying to
plaster this ceiling and I've got paid
150 pounds to do this which to me at the
time was massive money so I'm there
Plastering this ceiling and it's all
falling down on me and it's not working
and then I get home my mum's like hey
she says you know you okay and I'm
really stressed and now I've got my
schoolwork to do and I've got to plaster
this ceiling so
what I did is I thought okay if I can't
do it as a business person what do you
do when you can't do something as a
business person I'll tell you what you
do when you can't do something as a
business person what you have to do you
have to find someone else who can do it
that's see that's what that's what
business is generally at school right if
you can't do your exam you've got to
learn to do your exam you can't copy
someone else's work that's cheating
right in business it's a little bit
different in business how it works is if
you can't do something we have to do and
this is what I've learned to do in
business this is why even when I was at
school and I was sat on a special needs
desk and I was failing I've got ADHD
I've got dyslexia I can't tie my
freaking shoelaces but this is why I've
gone on to be able to make millions of
pounds because I've learned in business
that if you can't do something as long
as you can find somebody who can then
you can you can then be successful
because working together is better than
working on your own in business
so what I did was I found somebody on an
advert called indeed who was looking for
work as a plasterer and I said Tim this
is a little bit cheeky what I did but I
said to him I want to implore you
to come and work for me I didn't tell
him I was 15 years old because that
would have kind of put him off a little
bit I said I want to implore you to come
and work for me
but in order to get the job
you need to show me what you're capable
of I want to put you through a trial day
okay so he's like cool man his name's
Tom Thomas like cool man
what do I need to do
I said what it is you need to meet me
in Wolverhampton at this time this place
and we're going to spend a few hours
together and I want to watch your skills
so Tommy comes down Tommy meets me 9 A.M
Friday comes down meets me I said right
in order for me to implore you I need to
see your skills your first job Tommy I
want to watch you plaster this ceiling
now I couldn't pluster the ceiling
myself I don't know how to do it he's
doing it for free
because he's doing it because he wants a
potential job
so Tommy's like cool so Tommy starts
Plastering the ceiling within three
hours the ceiling is plastered it's
finished Tommy didn't get paid anything
I said to Tommy I said great job Tommy I
took my 150 quid from the lady that paid
me the jobs really don't it's beautiful
I then employed Tommy as a contractor
and Tommy was charging me Tommy wanted
70 pounds a day
so I was like okay cool I can pay you 70
pounds a day I then I'm 15 guys at this
time I'm 15. so Tommy wants 70 pound a
day I then put adverts in the papers and
I charge 150 pounds a day
so I'm like you want me to plaster it's
150 pounds a day so I'm at school
and I've got people going out for me
Plastering for 70 pounds a day when I'm
charging 150 pounds a day by the time I
left school when I was 16 years old I
had 3 500 pounds saved up in the bank
and I'm thinking man I didn't do super
well in school but I got 3 500 pounds
saved up I didn't do Super One in school
I'm not super smart but instead of
trying to do everything on my own I've
learned in business that you can get
people around you to help you because
it's not just what you know it's also
what people around you know so now I'm
16 and I I finished school when I was 16
years old
to finish school at 16 years old and I'm
thinking okay how can I use
my skills
okay my entrepreneurial skills to set up
a business make a lot of money help a
lot of people but when I left school
what I realized is I realized that money
is kind of like water
in the sense of water is always moving
right
so so you have a drink and then what
happens it comes out right goes in the
toilet flush it down goes off into the
ocean Rises up into the sky rains back
down it's always moving it's never still
and I realize money is like that
money's always moving so I thought when
I was 16 years old is I thought where is
the money at where's most of the money
falling where are the reservoirs where
are the streams and I and I started
reading books okay I even though I'm not
super smart and I'm not a great reader
it takes me probably 10 times longer to
read a book than many of you guys but I
thought I started reading books I read a
book by Richard Brampton Richard Branson
it also like me
suffers with dyslexia
um so he didn't do super well in school
I read Richard Branson's book it was
called screw it let's do it I read a
book by Robert Kiyosaki called Rich Dad
Poor Dad and I started studying money
and I realized that where most of the
money is if you look on the Sunday Times
rich list and you look at all the people
that are rich
Super Rich most of them are making money
in property
so I'm thinking property is the business
I want to do
however I've only got three and a half
thousand pounds
I'm 16 years old my parents were split
up my dad wants me to work on the market
stores with him my mom's a mobile
hairdresser
I'm not old enough to buy a house
I'm I ain't got enough money to buy a
house
so I'm thinking okay well how can I do
it so rather than trying to figure out
all the details
of how am I going to do it here's
another rule in business and a rule in
life if you want to be something
you've got to find people that are
already successful in that field and
you've got to hang around them
if you want to be a dancer guess what
you've got to do you got to go and join
a dance school you've got to find people
the dancers
and if you want to be
um a martial art expert you've got to
find people who are experts
so I thought okay so I went down to a
networking event
now I'm 16. not property similar right
to some of you in the room or just a
tiny bit older so I'm 16.
and I went down to this property
investors Network
I bought myself a suit
it cost me 24 pounds I went down to this
networking event and I got there and it
was in Birmingham just down the road
from here right we're in Leicester I'm
from Warsaw Wolverhampton she's in
Birmingham so I went to this networking
event in Birmingham I'm 16.
it's a property investors networking
event where all the rich people are
hanging out you've got people worth 100
million pounds 200 million pounds you've
got people with a hundred properties
land developers big farm Farmers with
loads of land I'm at this event I'm 16.
I've got three and a half thousand
pounds that I saved up while I was at
school
so so I'll get down to this event I'm in
the soup
and everybody the event's really rich
and when I signed in a reception I
suddenly feel really really nervous
I suddenly feel really uncomfortable I
start feeling a bit sick
I'm gonna tell you another rule in
business
if you want to be very successful
whether that's whether that's
academically whether that's in a career
in business dance if you want to be
really successful you have to get
comfortable
being uncomfortable
you have to get used to doing things
that scare you because if you just do
the same comfortable things again and
again and again if you never stretch
yourself you can never grow
so I'm feeling sick I'm at this
networking event
and they said I signed in and they said
Samuel network with everybody and have
fun so I'm walking around and there's
people coming up to me that are like 55
years old
with hundreds of houses that are looking
at me and they're saying so what's your
property investment strategy there
and I'm like I'm like a rabbit caught in
headlights I'm just like because I
didn't have a strategy I didn't have any
money I didn't have any credit
but what I learned is this
in business and in property next rule is
this I learned that
the marketplace I really believe this
I believe that the marketplace out there
in the real world
does not discriminate against you
what it wants the marketplace wants is
it wants you to be able to add value
what I mean by that is whether you are
black or white or whether you're a man
or woman or whatever you are whatever
your age is if you're 15 16 18 20. it
doesn't matter in business what matters
is how good you are in business what
matters is what value you can bring
so when I was 16 years old I learned a
skill and this skill made me very rich
the skill that I learned was how to find
and calculate good property Investments
so I started finding property
Investments even I'm 16. you know I've
got no money I started finding property
Investments
and then the people that I met on my
networking events
I would pass the deals to them and I
would charge a fee
so it's like I found a two hundred
thousand pound house
it's worth 200 but I've negotiated to
buy it for 150.
I've found 50 a 50 000 pound discount on
this house
I can't buy it because I'm broke
I can't buy it because I'm a teenager
but I've negotiated it I've found it and
then I'd present it to an investor and
they would pay me two percent of the of
the um two percent commission of the
purchase
so if it's a 200 000 pound house I'm
getting paid four thousand pounds
as a teenager I was I learned how to
make a thousand two thousand three
thousand pounds in one day
so from a school struggling
with dyslexia
still can't time my shoelaces I learned
how to make a thousand two thousand
three thousand pounds a day because I
got comfortable being uncomfortable
because I learned and studied business
I started finding houses and selling
houses and now started using the money
to buy my own houses and now
I own a castle
I own a big castle in um near
kidderminster in budley I own eight
pieces of land I'm developing on I build
houses from scratch my net worth is over
20 million pounds
and uh every year my business turns over
about 10 million pounds
making millions of pounds profit so the
reason I think um the reason I wanted to
speak to you this morning there is no
way to share with you
this morning I'm going to wrap up in a
second but it's because I wanted to
inspire you
and I wanted to show you that regardless
if you're super smart brilliant good if
you struggle okay no problem you need to
number one find out what you're good at
number two do whatever it takes and get
comfortable being uncomfortable number
three surround yourself with good
positive people and number four have
masses of belief and and go do whatever
it takes and if you do that we I don't
know what you maybe your dreams aren't
to be a multi-millionaire maybe your
dreams are to be something completely
different but whatever it is that you
aspire to do if you put the right work
in and if you get around the right
people I'm here to just inspire you and
say you know what it's possible man
it's possible because if I did it
you can do it I'm not paid to be here
today
I didn't get paid to be here today the
reason I'm here today is simply because
I remember what I was like at school and
I knew that when I was at school I would
have appreciated someone coming in from
from the business world and spending 15
20 minutes sharing with me so I hope
that's been helpful I'm really excited
about sharing about more in depth about
business later on with some of you guys
and talking about how to systemize a
business structure a business we're
gonna have a good time and I appreciate
your time have yourself a wonderful day
I've always wanted to start my own
business so learning from somebody I can
relate to because I've got dyslexia I've
got ADHD so it helps me know that if
even if because he struggled in school I
do as well so it helps me know that I
can relate to somebody who's who's
successfully alive so it shows me that
I've got something I can fall back on I
can look up to it's always have faith
always have faith in yourself because
you may feel like giving up at times and
obviously you may struggle in certain
aspects of school but just don't ever
give up with this session it might have
only lasted an hour but I'm so thankful
for Samuel for bring coming in today and
bringing this knowledge and bringing
this experience and showing everyone
here that I was able to be in this
session that no matter what you want to
do you can find success in it because no
matter who you are there's a market for
something you want to do the felt that
got me was 15 years old and making 3500
I mean that's quite a kind of special
and I'm at that age I was just at school
not doing anything it makes you think
that maybe I could do something and
money in that at my young age and start
nine instead of just wait till later
I'm happy Kim I was not having this
experience in that not many students get
serious like this is nice in our school
we've got lots of students that decide
to start their own businesses so having
that extra knowledge whether it's around
property or anything in general uh is
really really helpful if you're a
teacher or careers leader in a school
and you're considering having an
external speaker come in whether it's
for aspirations raising whether it's for
looking at property investment or
business in general it'd be really good
to get in touch with Samuel and see what
we can do